يعني عقده اجتماعنا اليوم في وقت تواجه
فيه المنطقه
الازمات الامنيه والسياسيه بالاضافه الى
تحدي التحديات
تحدياتي الابن الغذائي والمائي والصحي
وضروطي تامين
امدادات الطاقه
و سلاسل
التوريد والتعامل مع تداعيات التغير
المناخي
الاخوه والاصدقاء الاعزاء
مؤمن نحن في الاردن
للاستقرار وسلام العادل والشامل
والتعاون الاقليمي وخاصه في المجالات
الاقتصاديه والتنمويه
ومعالجه قضايا الفقر والبطاله وان مواجهته
تحدياتنا المشتركه
تستدعي عملا جماعيا
اثاره الايجابيه وهنا
لا بد لي من الاشاره الى مشاريع التعاون
بين الاردن والعراق
بالاضافه الى الاشقاء العرب سواء في
قطاعات الطاقه او الصناعه او النقل
التعاون الثلاثي بيننا في الاردن
والاشقاء في مصر والعراق
التحديات التي تواجهنا كثيرا
وتزداد تعقيدا لكننا نؤمن ايضا ان هذا
المؤتمر ينعقد من اجل خدمه مصالحنا
المشتركه لضمان امن العراق
اساسيا في منطقتنا
العمل معكم لتعميق شركاتنا خدمه لشعوبنا
نتائج شهاده
الشركات قويه وعمليه شكرا جزيلا والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
الكلمه الان
لدوله الاخ محمد شياع السوداني رئيس مجلس
الوزراء العراقي
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو والمعالي
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
يسرني ان اعرب نيابه عن العراق وشعبه
عن التقدير العالي للاشقائي والاصدقاء
الذين تواجدوا هنا للمشاركه ضمن مؤتمر
بغداد للتعاون والشراكه بنسخته الثانيه
واشكر اخي جلاله الملك عبد الله الثاني بن
الحسين
والمملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه
وحكومتها المضيافه وشعبها الشقيق على حسن
الاستقبال وكرم الضيافه
وجودته تنظيم هذا المؤتمر
نجتمع اليوم في عمان
والامل يحدونا بالمضي نحو تعزيز مسيره
العلاقات بين دولنا في مختلف المجالات
وتطوير وسيرتها بالشكل الذي يسهم في تحقيق
وارسائي قواعد الاستقرار
والرخاء والتنميه في المنطقه
ويفتح المجال واسعا امام سبل الحوار
والنقاش
لتبادل الاراء
وتعميق المفاهيم
ان فكره تاسيس مؤتمر بغداد
الجغرافي والاقليمي اضافه الى الدول
الصديقه
تتبنى حكومتنا نهجا منفتحا يهدف لبناء
شركات اقليميه ودوليه مبنيه على المصالح
المشتركه بما في ذلك انشاء المشاريع
الاستراتيجيه التكامليه لربط العراقي مع
محيطه الاقليمي
ونرى ان الاولويه الان تكمن في تعزيز
اواصر التعاون والشراكه بين دولنا من خلال
الترابط في البنى التحتيه والتكامل
الاقتصادي
والاستثمارات المتبادله التي تعزز وتقوي
روابط الاخوه والصداقه بين دولنا وشعوبنا
اننا نسعى للعمل معا للتحول الى دول مصنعه
من خلال انشاء مناطق صناعيه مشتركه
تستفيد من نقاط القوه والمنافسه لكل دوله
وتعزز من قدراتنا الصناعيه المشتركه وتربط
سلاسل القيمه المضافه لكل منا ضمن سلسله
متكامله قادره على المنافسه في الاسواق
العالميه
واطلاق المشاريع العملاقه في شتى
القطاعاتهم
والغاز والزراعه والصحه والتعليم والسياحه
ومن الضروري ايضا التركيز على قطاع
الخدمات وتطويره واعتباره احد اهم محركات
الاقتصاد في دولنا ومنطقتنا بالاضافه الى
معالجه مشكله البطاله من خلال تنميه
القطاع الخاص المنتج وتحسين ظروف العمل
فيه وتوفير الضمانات اللازمه للعاملين
وعلى الصعيد الداخلي
فاننا وضعنا مكافحه الفساد المالي
والاداري في صلب اولوياتنا وقد بدانا
عمليه حمله مكافحه الفساد
بدء من اعلى المستويات
ونطلب من الدول الشقيقه
في استرداد اموال العراق المنهوبه
والمهربه وتسليم المطلوبين الذين يتخذون
من هذه الدول المحل اقامه لهم
وتعملوا حكومتنا بجد على تحسين البيئه
الاستثماريه في العراق من حيث التشريعات
والاجراءات والضمانات لتمكين المستثمرين
من دخول اسواقنا والافاده من الفرص
الكبيره فيها
ان البيئه الاستثماريه الملائمه بحاجه الى
استتباب الامن وقد حققنا الاستقرار الامني
في العراق بعد الانتصارات الكبيره على
فلول الارهاب والجماعات التكفيريه ولا
يفوتني هنا ان اقف اجلالا للدماء الزكيه
والتضحيات التي بذلتها قواتنا المسلحه
بصنوفها كافه دفاعا عن النفس والمنطقه
والعالم وان اشكرك كل من وقف معنا حتى
تحقق نصرنا الكبير
ولابد لنا جميعا من مواصله العمل المشترك
والتكاتفي لمحاربه الفكر المتطرف بجميع
اشكاله ووضع اليات وبرامج حقيقيه لفتح
النوايا الخبيثه للارهابيين الذين يجندون
الشباب بافكارهم الهدامه المدمر لشعوبنا
ودولنا ومنطقتنا والعالم اجمع فالارهاب لا
يقفوا عند احد
اخواني واخواتي واصدقائي ان العراقي يواجه
تهديدا وجوديا بسبب شح المياه وانما
عازمنا على العمل الجاد مع جيراننا في
الجمهوريه التركيه والجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه بضمان امن الى الماء والتوسل
الى افضل السبل للاداره المشتركه للموارد
المائيه العابره للحدود ووصول حصتنا
المائيه وفق الاتفاقيات والقوانين الدوليه
وبما يساعد على دعم التعاون وتحقيق
التنميه والاستقرار
بالتوازي مع ذلك فاننا بدانا باخذ الخطوات
العمليه لتعزيز استخدام انظمه الري
الحديثه وايقاف هدر المياه في الخزنه
والزراعه
اننا نعتبر التلوث البيئي في الهواء
والمياه والتربه من اهم المخاطر على
مستقبل شعبنا خصوصا في المناطق الجنوبيه
وقد بدانا العمل الجاد لمعالجه حرق الغاز
المصاحب في الحقول النفطيه وندعو الشركات
العالميه للاستثمار في هذا المجال لاجل
تحويل استخدامها هذا المصدر المهم للطاقه
لاغراض توليد الكهرباء سعيا نحو تحقيق
الاكتفاء الذاتي في استعمال الغاز لتوليد
الكهرباء على المدى المتوسط ولتقلين
انبعاث الغازات الدفيئه والاحتباس الحراري
اعزائي نرى ان سلسله المؤتمرات هذه هي
بمثابه نافذه المعززه لجهود توسيع التعاون
الاقليمي ومن هذا المنطلق ورغبه العراق
بالوصول الى اقصى درجات التفاهم والتنسيق
حول دعم عجله التطوير والتنميه في المنطقه
واقامه افضل الروابط والصلات مع دولها
نؤكد ان العراق متمسكن ببناء علاقات تعاون
وثيقه ومتوازنه مع كل الشركاء الاقليميين
والدوليين
وينها بنفسه عن اصطفافات المحاور واجواء
التصعيد
وينشدوا سياسه التهدئه وخفض التوترات وفي
ذات الوقت يرفض التدخل بشؤونه الداخليه
ومس سيادته او الاعتداء على اراضيه
ولا يمكن اعتماد مبدا القوه في في مساعي
حل الخلافي او الاختلاف ولا نسمح باستخدام
هذا المبدا ضد العراق بنفس الوقت لا نقبل
ان ينطلق اي وتهديد من العراق ضد اي دوله
من دول الجوار او المنطقه
واجبنا ان نعتمد الحوار والتفاهم لحل
مشاكلنا ونبني على ما يجمعنا لفتح الافاق
نحو اقامه الشراكات الاقليميه الشامله
وتعظيم الاعتماديه بين دولنا التي تسهم في
تعزيز اخوتنا المستنده الى عوامل التاريخ
والجغرافيا والثقافه وتؤسسه للاستقرار
والازدهار في المنطقه لذلك يسعى العراق
لان يكون راعيا للتواصل والتحاور كسبيل
اساس لحل الخلافات ونشكر الحضور على دع
بجهود العراق في هذا المجال
بهدف تهديئه الاجواء وتقريبي وجهات النظر
بين الفرقاء وعززت من جهوده الدبلوماسيه
في نزع فتيل الازمات في المنطقه ختامه
نجدد التاكيد على الاهميه التي نوليها
لمؤتمرنا هذا للخروج بالنتائج المرجوه
التي تعزز الفرص والتطلعات نحو التعميق
اواصر العمل الاقليمي والدولي المشترك
وصولا الى تحقيق الاستقرار والازدهار
الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي والتنموي في منطقتنا والمضي
قدما بتنشيط اليات التعاون والشراكه بين
دولنا وشعوبنا وتعميقها وتعزيزها والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
شكرا دوله الرئيس مات نوم اكسيلونس
ايمان
صديقي
وزراء جمهوريه العراق السيد محمد الشيعه
السوداني الذي نظمنا معه هذا المؤتمر الذي
قال لنا بوضوح للتو ما يريد
الوعد الذي قدمناه السنه الماضيه في بغداد
ان نجتمع مره اخرى لنجدد التزامنا لمساحه
العراق وامنه واستقراره واحترامي سيادته
ورخاء شعبه هذه هي قبل كل شيء مهمته
السلطات العراقيه ولكن ليس وحدها جيران
العراق او ان العراق اليوم هو مسرحا
لتاثيرات وانتهاكات وسع ساعه استقرار تؤثر
على المنطقه وبالتالي اهميه ان عقيده همم
هذا المؤتمر بهذه التشكيله وان تجتمعها
حول الطاوله في هذه القاعه كل الدول
والامم التي يمكنها ان تساهم في تحسيس
سياده العراق وبالتالي امن واستقرار
المنطقه
هي في قلبي تاريخ البشريه وهمم
كثيره من حلولي وتوترات السياسيه في
السنوات الماضيه الشهور الماضيه بينت
والشهور الى ستبين كم ان هذه المنطقه هي
في قلبي التحديات الكبرى ويكفي ان ننظر
الى ما يحصل هل اتجرا على ذكر ذلك ولكن
انتهينا لتونا منك كاس العالم الكره القدم
للمره الاولى في دوله عربيه في قطر واهني
وقطر على تنظيمها منذ بدعه اسابيع انتهى
مؤتمر الاطراف لتغيرات المناخيه كان في
مصر واهنئ صديقي الرئيس السيسي الذي تمكن
من جمع العالم ومن حل بعض المشاكل خاصه
تلك المتعلقه بالاضرار والخسائر وهذه كانت
مساله اساسيه والمؤتمر المقبل للاطراف
لمكافحه التغيرات المناخيه سين عقده في
الامارات العربيه المتحده وهذا يبين كم
انا هذه المنطقه تصبح مركزه ثقل
الدبلوماسيا اضافه الى مؤتمر اليوم ولكن
هذه الرغم من كل ذلك لا تزال تعاني من
جمود من قصه
ذلك همم
تدخلات والمشاكل الامنيه
لا شك في ان العراق نظرا لما حصل في همم
عقود الماضيه هو من اولي الضحايا في عمليه
زعزعه الاستقرار هذه ذكرت كل هذه الاحداث
الدبلوماسيه الدوليه ان كانت رياضيه او
مناخيه او دبلوماسيه بحته لابين ان هذه
المنطقه لها او تمتلك كل ما تحتاجه لكي
تذهب ابعد في المشاركه في الجده العالميه
ولكن يتعينوا علينا ان تجاوز وان نتخطى
انقسامات همم الانيه التي نراها لماذا
فرنسا فرنسا
اعتقد ان
هو من الناحيه الجغرافيه فرنسا لا تنتمي
لهذه المنطقه وهذا امر واقع ولن احاول ان
ندافع عن هذا النظريه المعاكسه ولكن بحكم
تاريخنا وعملنا الدبلوماسيه والعمل الذي
قمنا به في السنوات الماضيه اود ان اؤكد
لكم على حرص فرنسا على استقرار وامن هذه
المنطقه والعمل بكل صدق وامانه مع كل واحد
منكم لكي لا تكون هناك اصوات تملي دروسا
من الخارج ولا تفرض امورا ولكن